this woman but I would never gone to
school one day in her life with $2,500
she built a business which he sold me
for 60 million dollars approximately but
because you spent so much time dreaming
thinking and planning for this giant
thing you never actually do anything you
make a decision and you're like I know
this is gonna be difficult I know it's
not gonna be the easiest thing in the
world but I'm determined to do it rise
and shine it's an espresso time what's
up believe nation its Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message be determined to succeed
over to you Warren Buffett I would like
to tell you of two women that each sold
the business to Berkshire Hathaway to me
actually for many many many millions of
dollars both of them started with twenty
five hundred dollars by a coincidence
was the exact same Ahmad it was
everything they had in the world
and one of them was a woman who landed
in Seattle in 1917 couldn't speak a word
of English had a tag around her neck the
tag said Fort Dodge Iowa the Red Cross
got her a Ford dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who would come
to the country a couple years earlier
and she lived in Fort Dodge for two
years and as she put it she felt like a
dummy she couldn't pick up the language
and she couldn't learn a word and so she
decided and she and her husband decided
to move to Omaha so they came to Omaha
in 1990
and there she found a small colony of
Russian Jews so she started feeling more
at home and then as her oldest daughter
went to school she would come on this
daughter Frances and she would teach her
mother the words that she learned in
school that day and this woman rose
bumpkin spent 20 years saving money
bringing first her siblings over her
mother and father fifty dollars at a
time she sold used clothing to do it she
had four children during this period and
by 1937 after 20 years
she saved twenty-five hundred dollars
she went to Chicago and she bought but
she could have furniture her dream had
always been to open a furniture store
and this woman would never gone to
school one day in her life with $2,500
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream she
built a business which he sold to me in
1983 for 60 million dollars
approximately in which which did a
billion and a half dollars worth of
business last year the fourth generation
is working in that business
this woman rose blumpkin lived while she
she worked for me until she was 103 and
then I'm not said then she retired and
she died the next year which is a lesson
to all of her church managers it
pretty mature retirement nothing you
can't tell what's going to happen but
mrs. B with her $2,500 one further fact
about her she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed she knew she
could outwork anyone else
she knows she cared about her customers
she worked at Murray Lowell gross
margins but she built this incredible
business determination is a game whoever
you look up to whichever athlete
entrepreneur musician whoever it is that
you look up to study their story and
you'll see that as one of determination
that didn't just get handed to them that
they worked and they worked then they
worked and they worked and they failed
and they sucked and eventually they won
and so I think what happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs a lot of people who are
just getting started is they try it they
taste it it doesn't work you create
something that's not good maybe you
invest some dollars into it it doesn't
work out and because it didn't work out
that first time you throw in the towel
and you're never gonna get take your
shot again
that's what most people do and so the
two things that come to mind around this
topic is one whenever you get some big
idea something you want to do just start
find the smallest possible silliest
stupidest smallest way to just start a
lot of times we get these ideas and then
we make them big which is what we love
doing as entrepreneurs right we're
visionaries with dreamers we want to
make something really big how kind of
make this thing explode and then you
make this thing so big in your mind that
you never do anything about it right if
you want to start a YouTube channel I
had a I had a fan Yoko come in earlier
today she wants to have a YouTube
channel great so to do that you need to
have here and you need to have lights
and what camera should I have and what
microphone should I use and it just
keeps building and building and building
becomes this impossible thing that you
need tons of money before you ever
launch and that's it's great to think of
it from a motivating point of view of
where your channel could go but because
you spend so much time dreaming thinking
and planning for this giant thing you
never actually do anything if you want
to start a YouTube channel pull out your
phone and just start filming
I'll still film some of my videos off my
phone last month I didn't have Jason my
awesome cameraman I was traveling I was
on a cruise I was seasick and I'm still
feeling off of my phone and the videos
are still doing well you know and so if
I could do it on my channel with 1.2
million subscribers you could do it on
your channel and so break that down into
whatever situation you're facing because
if YouTube may not be your game just
find the smallest way to start find the
smallest way to start yes have a big
dream that's gonna motivate you and
inspire you and find the smallest way to
get started right now as soon as you get
any kind of goal or vision for yourself
then today has something has to happen
action has to happen beyond just
planning action you want to start a
YouTube channel make your video today go
with your phone make your video today it
might take you the whole day but make
that video the second part of it is
expect your work at the beginning to
suck expect it not to work out like
might be does at the beginning I had no
comments on I had no feedback I had no
traction whenever you learn anything you
suck whatever the first thing is that
you are trying to learn you're trying to
learn a language you're trying to learn
how to make coffee you're going to learn
how to make a video
anything you suck at it the start you
suck any skill that you've ever learned
you sucked at the beginning your first
project was a disaster and yet you
expect this business idea of yours to
just work out the first time you try
something it won't
so yes have a big goal yes have a big
vision and find a way to start small and
then expect to suck expect that first
project to not go well to be a total
embarrassment especially if you know
what looks good and you know you can't
do it expecting to be a total
embarrassment but the wind for you is
not in creating the quality product the
win is getting started the win is doing
something about it
the win is building some kind of
momentum and then tomorrow doing it
again and doing it again and doing the
weekend and every day making it a little
bit better and so yes you could aspire
to be like the people that you look up
to and use that as a kick forward to say
I'm not good enough yet I want to get
better I want to get stronger I want to
be the best I need to drive forward I
need to improve myself but use that as a
kick forward not down because if you
look at the people where the best say I
can never do
that's when you start to lose so use
them as a source of inspiration to go
forward and then just try to be better
than you were yesterday like the video
you made today or the project you made
today or whatever you're working on
whatever skill you're trying to master
you did better today than you did
yesterday and the day before and the day
before and the day before and that's
ultimately how you win it's a story of
every single successful person if you
don't believe me go and look up whoever
it is that you look up to the masters in
your field and study their history study
how they got started study how much
determination and passion hard work went
into it study how much they did on a
daily basis not starting and stopping
and starting and stopping every single
day and four years later they became a
success that's the kind of attitude you
need to take I like to say that you have
to be patient and impatient but I think
people have it messed up I think you
need to be patient in the long term I
think you need to have patience for
where you're going and understand it's
going to take a lot of time and be
impatient in the day to day be impatient
in like this video that I'm making I
want it to be the best video possible I
want it to be the best version of what I
can do given my current skills and
abilities and resources right now this
needs to be the best version so I'm
impatient on the daily but patient
knowing that for me to hit my next goal
it's gonna take more years like for me
to accomplish my mission it's a lifetime
thing where most people haven't flipped
most people are impatient on a long term
like they've needed everything to happen
right away they need their big goal to
happen tomorrow or they're not happy and
they're so patient with themselves on a
daily basis they skate by like they make
a video they make a little project and
they're not hard enough on themselves so
I think you need that balance of
patience and impatience but you need to
flip the way you're thinking about it
right now you need to stay determined
you need to stay focused because that's
ultimately how you work now I've got a
really special bonus clip that is team
will approved coming up next but before
that I want to know what is your
favorite story of determination
what story inspires you motivates you I
want you to share down the comments
below because I think it could also help
inspire the other people watching and
maybe even give me some ideas for new
videos to make so thank you guys so much
for watching put it in the comments
below I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot Ivan's press oh and enjoy
the bonus clip
[Music]
it's just like anything you're gonna do
yet you know when I wanted to become an
actor and start making movies it was the
same kind of determination the same kind
of thing where you're like you make a
decision and you're like I know this is
gonna be difficult I know it's not gonna
be the easiest thing in the world but
I'm determined to do it and I really
care I'm really caring about this
decision so you just make it a priority
and you know when anyone's starting out
in any business or any sort of life
endeavor or any sort of relationship
you're starting out with the intention
to go all the way and to me it was just
a decision and I just made a commitment
to sticking to it you must have as a
basic principle the determination to
achieve excellence in your various
fields of endeavor you're going to be
deciding as the days and the years
unfold what you will do in life what
your life's work will be and once you
discover what it will be set out to do
it and to do it well if it falls you'll
love to be a streetsweeper sweep streets
like Michelangelo painted pictures sweep
streets like Beethoven from Paul's music
sweep streets like Liam teen pricings
before the myths of Metropolitan Opera
and sweep streets like Shakespeare wrote
poetry sweep streets so well that all
the hosts of heaven and earth will have
to pause and say here lived a great
street sweeper who swept his job well
[Applause]
if you can't be applying on the top of
the he'll be a scrub in Diwali but be
the best little scrub on the side of the
real be a bush if you can't be a tree if
you can't be a highway just be a trail
if you can't be the Sun be a star for
isn't my size and you win are you fail
be the best of whatever you are the most
important ever if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details